oh like hit it whack it slap it yes
you know what i keep thinking about you
you and your friend splitting a tooth
off is so funny to
it was actually a corvette and we're
doing corrections from last week and it
was not we were not going to split
me and my friend when we were 10. it was
not a trans am it was actually
a corvette oh splitting a tea top is so
funny i think it was a corvette with a
t-top though
it is funnier with a t-top everyone gets
an l because it makes the separation for
you
it's just yeah um i did i
tell the story about how my brother and
sister joey and sheila
had a car that they said there was a
joey and sheila come on
we got them all um it's a big family
what kind of names you need
um i got a peter um they're all like
irish cats
like they're all bible names man there's
a [ __ ] marriage yeah
joey chile had a car that they split and
the deal was
whoever was in the car when it
like broke what like needed a repair
you had to pay for it so they would just
say dude
right so they would just like push it
into the driveway
smoking and be like and then the next
morning be like it was fine for me
you're right
um that's the kind of family guys that's
where i that's
where i live that's my origin story
bianca how was your week are you
freaking out
um you know i do
have some holes in this story but i do
remember
some holes in the story great but i
remember something that i
i actually think everyone would find
very funny
on this podcast i don't know if i did i
tell you about the guy who said the
who just said the thing to me that was
weird which thing
i don't think i did stop me if you've
heard this one um
so i was with my friends and his
apartment complex
and a new person had just moved in so
they do the like
hey i'm just i'm at yeah
and he's like hey hey hey hey ma'am
like yeah i'm doing right he mammed me i
mean he's a friend of mine already
great well he's you're about to i don't
know if you might in front anyway so
you can say hey ma'am you know yeah i
mean blah blah
loving let me know i was like oh yeah
you also i don't live here and you don't
have to call me ma'am
he's like sorry you know i just came
back from hawaii so
i should have said uh sista and i was
like he's white
he's white and i was like
he's my best friend
and i looked at him like he had two head
sister
and i'm like i i didn't i i just like
blankly stared at him and he
started getting nervous like oh uh sorry
i
i'm from venice really that's why i'm
wearing this and it was like
a tie-dye shirt he bombed so
and then he ran away trouble bombed him
did he have did he actually
not walk did he walk fast or he jogged
he scurried you should have to jog away
if you're bombing
that would be the i'm gonna i'm gonna
implement that in my own life
if i'm bombing badly enough i just take
off reds
there's an old story i don't have the
details of this story exactly right
come on i feel like dave may have retold
this story
when we walked around in dc where the
guy bombed
a guy on an open mic bomb really bad oh
yes
and it was pouring rain yes and dave
said
uh the guy was like i just don't know
how that audience
will ever will ever look at me again
dave goes like don't worry man
the audience will forgive you and the
guy goes yeah but well
god forgive me and runs off into the
rain
which you should have to do that when
you bomb
um will god forgive you um what did you
do
i the big the lead the my top story is
jesus um i don't know what happened in
the last
90 seconds to that queue but it just
blasted our ears out and we're not
wearing headphones
yeah just um
i okay you know that i
i rolf right uh no i actually thought
you meant throwing up
nope rolfing it is a type of
organizational osteopathic massage
yes okay i'm building rebuilding my walk
rebuilding my posture rebuilding my
balance
in talking to this guy and talking to
his wife who
who does some [ __ ] with your head
um i heard i hear the term
um divergent vision
right and i'm thinking is that
seeing double but i kind of am like huh
you ever do i ever do this on here yeah
i just closed an eye
it's because i don't my vision's not
unified
and it's does that mean your eyes are
offset well you can see one of my eyes
is lower than the other one
just physically look at me this is very
good podcasting
oh okay okay yes so
so uh so my eyes are off
so basically i do this
because my it's it it just gets
confusing to for my brain to
organize it so yeah he like squints and
closes one eye
i close one eye right my dad used to do
it maybe some of you remember my dad
doing it
uh legendary podcaster my dad
and uh sheila father of sheila was the
name of the podcast
um uh my brother kevin used to do a joke
i have ten kids but don't worry we're
not close um
uh so he he used to do it and i noticed
myself doing it and just didn't think
anything of it
so there's a so i go to the eye the guy
the roffer recommends an eye doctor
and i get my eyes i get an eye
like more eye tests than i've ever done
right just more even with glasses like
so at one point there's a thing where in
the right
spectrum or the right side uh
there is a red dot right and on the left
side there is a bunch of numbers going
uh one through ten on a diagonal basis
right
and he and he's like all right open both
eyes where is the red dot
right because it should unify i'm like
i have no idea i knew it was there
but i couldn't tell you couldn't so you
could see it you just couldn't tell
where it was
where it was relative to the [ __ ] in my
left eye that's weird you know that's
like those online like
if you stare at this yeah things move
yes
except because of this i apparently have
no depth perception
relative to most people you got rods and
cones old
i mean no i i've never gotten i've never
bumped into people i don't have balances
you don't have like astigmatism
i have whatever i've vision stuff but
that's anybody what i'm saying is
i don't have um
my brain basically all right so the guy
said the guy can't tell any medical
stories
he can't tell i had a patient who except
for one person
carl lewis the the runner yes right
another great dave story which is
he saw carlos once dave's on trooms carl
lewis is running
he's just jogging recreationally but
it's literally the funniest thing in the
world that carl lewis could be doing
anyhow i
carl lewis had it got it
fixed and was like i was jumping
too early on the long jump because i
didn't have
the right depth perception like he was
it was [ __ ] up his
he's a jumper it's a long jumper right
it was like it was a
so you i don't have depth perception the
way most people do
i will get it and then apparently the
world will be like incredibly
so you're going to get it based on your
walk
i'm going to get it yeah kind of i mean
your watch is going to help well they
just
mentioned it at the walking class that i
take
um they mentioned it and i was like wait
what and he was like yeah there's a
thing
and i was like i think i have that oh
and then you separately want to go
okay and he's like call this guy did it
so what's the name of that thing
that you've got going on binocular
dysfunction
i know it's funny binocular like i got
dysfunction
yeah binocular dysfunction um will was
too busy
hitting neil's old man phrases
it comes out when you type in binocular
yeah so
it's i'm going apparently it causes
anxiety which would explain a lot
although i don't think of myself as
anxious
um headaches neck pain and
nausea with motion sickness man
incredibly nauseous with so we'll see
what happens guys
maybe next summer i'll be on your boat
i'll be on
it's one of our lucky listeners boats
we'll do a [ __ ] hold on i'm not okay
ready doing pro i'm not done doing promo
excuse me the solution is i can get
surgery
i can wear glasses that have a prism in
the middle
he said just do exercises oh um
so i'm just going to start actually i'm
going to start prism
when i'm finished with my walking class
i'll go to my lo my vision class
uh you should just buy the prism glasses
because you just like to buy [ __ ]
you know what you're right you're
exactly right hello doctor you're
welcome
um so so i'm going to be jumping
probably further than carlos as well
that's my understanding
well you know we have to do your we got
to show them your walk
i know i will get there we have too much
equipment now
too much good we will have to do just
can we explain things
can't we just splice it in later but
it's bad podcast
we'll do it later yeah but we'll do it
very interesting
so that's kind of the lead story and uh
i did ayahuasca yesterday but that's
neither here nor
burying the league but it's not it's
it's just a part of my life
yeah nothing's wrong nothing's right
everything's fine
you know what man um i'm going to new
york for a long time
yeah i'm not going to be able to drink
the plant
and there's no ayah in there is i just
don't
i don't uh i don't trust people
who aren't the person to do it right
right no
so you've learned that the whole way the
hardest of most
you first you first me of course um
so uh so yeah so
uh i uh is i need the
empathy that's why i do it
i need the empathy straight up it
reminds me of
um makes me empathetic and it makes me
remember the being in the center
of it of at all okay so i hope
you asked you asked i've been there
old west plant medicine welcome to old
west plant management
you now you done took my san pedro
cactus
off of my property line not squat with
your spurs
okay um okay well that's good i'm happy
tell me anything besides the guy like i
see
sister sister don't say see stuff
two sisters pretty great pretty [ __ ]
good
sister not even sister right no not it
was in hey sister rap with me
it was like oh sorry uh sister
yeah again i don't know where because
you don't even really give off like a
patchouli
bamboo vibration um
[Music]
yeah i mean that is the name of an
incense somewhere outside of a nightmare
probably
well the greatest bad dude fact of all
time is you know that
where she would wear the african
headdress yeah
in africa they called it a bad dew
headdress
no swear to god they because nobody
really wears them everyone was like girl
yeah bad dude headdress comes up how to
do a head wrap
they're all white people as well how do
you do an african head wrap yeah
here we go um anyhow it's on
it's untraceable that story um
it's really interesting what do africans
call
20 years ago what do africans call deer
a non-existent internet
1995 internet um
netscape um tell us netscape
what was the one explorer microsoft
internet you know they just got rid of
it
like a year ago yeah well what are they
gonna do there were people
i know people with bad addresses like
that was on yahoo until recently what
happens when someone gives you aol
i'd pray for them that's why i go to
that's why i go to iowa
i pray for people with aol somebody
funny has aol like somebody that's way
beyond aol
like a
i think it's i think too short has aol
that's funny
i mean i can remember when he gave me
his email there was an aol in it it's a
wild time
um tell me is that all all you have to
talk about
i think that's all that's right i have
binocular dysfunction and i'm addicted
to plant matter oh no i have to talk
about something else
what guys i who knew the ethiopia shirt
was
uh such a huge oh people love these yeah
people needed
information and let me tell you there
was not a sista
in sight that bianca was wearing an
ethiopia shirt last week
it was cool it was ethiopia and then it
had like uh
you know like it said have habits which
is like the word
in amharic for ethiopian um and then it
said
habisha then like the h stands for like
happiness yeah whatever all that um it's
hella vintage you guys you can't
it's a one of one i got it from vintage
store i'm sorry
everyone asked me like where did you get
it let me send me the link
the funny thing is if it was new you
wouldn't buy it
do you know because it's like it just
looks like a weird
outside church barbershop well i can get
down though but
yeah i know but it's you know what i
mean like it's a little too
yeah if it wasn't it'd be like you
wouldn't wear a silk the
shocker shirt new but if you wear it
vintage speak for yourself
well now vintage you'd wear it then
they're cool who's
it's all vintage who's making silk the
jogger bianca it seems like if i
am you don't know um
there's a market apparently bianca is
becoming a funny t-shirt person based on
the ethiopian last week because now
she's wearing
no this is just i just i'm comfortable
this is
you're not one of these people this is a
uh this is my from my x-files love
sure extraterrestrial beats
um i want to believe great no i know
just do us all a favor don't turn into
one of those funny t-shirt people
yeah um right and also like then i gotta
go
what the chart about this week bianca
this is just
i mean i wear these shirts i go of
course you're just a human being who
happens to be doing a podcast you're not
and sometimes think about it damns need
it [ __ ]
great come on come on come on come on
anyhow what about you come on did you do
something now you have to add one
you have to add something i already did
uh plant medicine and
plant and uh and by the way
[Music]
i did comedy uh i had to follow maron
twice
and the only problem is we have some
very similar
kova jokes and it's like [ __ ] so i have
to either not do mine or be like mark
mentioned
right uh the mark so whatever but it's
fun
are you gonna when you go to new york do
you like doing stand up better in new
york or l.a
uh standard wise not like
crowded i guess new york because it's
just more
you can do whoa you can do 20.
in new york you can do i can't do it
in new york see hip hop
in new york well just drops for a second
yeah drop keep dropping funk infused
beats
[Music]
bad dude great that and and it works
with the attaboy bird
my mic thing fell out of the table it's
fine guys we're fine don't
there's not going to be a kickstarter to
save us um
the new york's better i just like you
can do nine spots with the seller and
so selfishly you can just like yeah it's
just just do more reps
um um
anyhow there was a whole world bianca
that had nothing to do with us
unfortunately um so
kamala was in south america
and she said don't come to
any migrants
uh she was in guatemala central america
i always called south america
forget about central central central sea
star
um uh and she said
don't come to immigrants and uh you know
who got upset about it do not come do
not come she said it twice
when you know when a black woman says
something's why uh the united states
will continue to enforce our laws and
secure borders
um you know who didn't like
that is uh liberals
aoc condemned it apparently that's what
the headline said
um and this is to what
and i say this to to liberals all the
time how many people should we let in
how many is it just as many as show up
is there a limit is there how'd you come
to that number
talk to me and and the truth is they
never have a number
they just don't have a number so it's
like is it infinite
that like people that and i'm not
talking about political
asylum i'm talking about the border
like crossing the border illegally
um how many of those people should we
admit or encourage it just it feels like
a
mayor of new york situation because
you're not really going to get
you can't say come mm-hmm you can't be
like
right well we're welcoming you this is
in a situation where we need like
you know in history some countries will
invite migrant workers for a certain
thing
this is it is don't know like tech jobs
jobs in the tech sector they'll invite
migrant yeah go ahead um
i'm going to build a bridge uh so no so
like
i'm just i don't know what the right
thing would have been
for her to say i mean she can't was she
asked about it yeah
she was she was asked she was dodging um
making the dangerous trick she said that
it's dangerous they get exploited
it's too dangerous so just don't come
and you won't be let in the problem is
that
saying you're a refugee for like a polit
like seeking political or not political
but just like
you know asylum is a legal way
a legal way yes a legal yeah way to
enter this country too
right so but you have to prove it
you have to prove [ __ ] the trump
administration made the
burden of proof like very high if they
even allowed
asylum they may yeah they just they kind
of just
they may have just shut it down i don't
even think they passed policies they
were just like
no um but there's a it's a fact
so don't expect us to know what it is
but trump did something with asylum we
think
there's no way for us to know based on
what is that
trump asylum is what he makes it he made
it harder
how about that so um so that's pretty
close
that's right so i don't know
if she was [ __ ] yeah like what do you
like pick your poison
right you want to say don't you want to
say come and then fox news attacks you
or don't come and aoc and people to the
left of you attack
i also think people i also think
liberals aren't saying
come on in like open come we're open
we're fine
like there's nobody that's actually
saying that so
i don't know what the backlash was
about yeah the energy is come on in
the energy is the energy is
don't not come that's confused and
that's a you wouldn't if someone if
there was someone who's having a branch
and they said don't not come
you'd be like you know what [ __ ] you
neil would not go
i'm [ __ ] i'm not going even with you
could send me an invite
like puffy and i'm not coming with like
eggs
and other like props from brunch and i'd
be like [ __ ] in a
in a hickory box not coming to brunch
um again i may never go to another party
for the rest of my life
and you said that pre-koved and then you
had a moment there where you were like i
don't know if that was the right thing
to say
well now i'm saying it again and i may
change my mind
were you ever at a party was i ever at a
party since you said it
no but i may not be i may never uh
i went to a party last february there's
one party i might go to
what about your own wrap party uh
i i try to lay low on that
you irish goodbye uh yeah i thought of
an irish goodbye
i was watching in the heights and i
don't know what the punchline is
you were watching in the heights i
cannot i was cooking and i was like let
me see what this you were
and i literally forgot they sang i just
forgot
they sang you forgot the guy from
hamilton yes i just thought
like i was gonna be like papi i didn't
know what it was gonna be
i i didn't think it through and then and
they were saying i was like oh [ __ ] they
sing
but i was the irish goodbye
um i'm trying to cr i don't know what
the what the punchline is
but uh dominican goodbye which
is it takes 45 minutes because there's
cousins and you got to kiss people and
you got to take selfies and you got
a bunch of [ __ ] i don't know it can
apply to a lot of people no they can buy
a lot of groups puerto rican goodbyes
dominican
[ __ ] haitian goodbyes persian goodbye
you're never leaving you're never
leaving um they'd never have it's still
happening
um you've been trying to leave this
podcast for two years um
uh so something i thought of
that's i sort of rate i think of racist
tropes
right and that's one uh what would be
some alternative goodbyes
uh so so something good came out of
watching yes the one song i watched
in the heights um
that was i got to in the heights title
sequence
and then what's fun the problem with
musicals that would make me a little
crazy is
every ending has to be uh just
crazy and not and i know it's like well
what about con stand up you need a
punch line but the punch line usually
isn't a faster pace
louder different genre tempo change
it can be if it's a song usually but
right
if you're doing a voice but you if i do
it
that's like the it's the punch line
musicals would make me insane meet me in
saint louis
you're asking for approval so much in
musicals
it would make me a little crazy now the
audience is more apt to give your
approvals approvals
because it's mostly housewife how's life
how's that yeah you watch hamilton no
i don't like musicals and i the hamilton
it's a wrap you like rap i don't i like
degenerates wrapping full stop and i
made that clear
yeah you know like i want you to have a
record i want you to go back
i want you to have just come home i want
you to be bad with money
i want you to be bad with women i have
many children
you don't know some of that i don't
acknowledge that i mean i want
trouble okay okay so sheesh
that i don't want to learn you don't
want to learn i only want to learn about
drugs
that's it okay so it's all about drugs a
wrapping
wrapping music without drugs i would yes
the game
like the game yes what's the game the
game just the rap the the drug game the
rat
game the no no the drug or the kelsey
grammer no no the drug game
oh the drug yeah um if you want to do a
musical about that
i'm right there did you i'm right there
you like dead press
the dead president sorry the movie yeah
i think i haven't seen it in 25 years i
just mean like so you like that genre
yeah everybody likes that genre i know
but you seem to really specifically like
that
no no for i don't mean it doesn't apply
to every like
on when movies it's got to be about
drugs i'm saying
rappers have to rap about degenerate
[ __ ]
or uh
like what kendrick does which is rap
about right trying to not
be degenerate [ __ ] macklemore mclemore
didn't
i probably haven't heard of michael
moore song all the way through um need
it to be you need to be try if you're
you have to be tempted no conscious rap
i mean i the guys who are
conscious are pretty like it's
even they're kind of still talking about
drugs right just a different point of
view
so just make it about drugs guys you're
gonna rap
let me let me know what it's about ahead
of time
and if it's about drugs i'll give it a
list um
now speaking of drugs
hunter biden now neil it's not about
drugs
neil it's not about drugs hunter would
be cast in your
drug musical um
so hunter there it is will
so hunter biden texted
a white person with the n-word which
is like what are white people doing yes
for real
but when we go ahead when you read them
it's like
not news oh of course it's not
they're just still trying to like get
joe go to his
uh actual texts true dat
[ __ ] is what he writes
it's so annoying when you interject with
ravelry is that what says i can't fool
that i can't read that far
true dat [ __ ] i'm done with my rant
it's like this is just it's i i like
i would say it's corny show me a white
crackhead that doesn't say the n-word
guy's like [ __ ] crackhead right but
lived in a motel with a woman he won't
in the book apparently just uses by like
a fake name
that he like i think she would seem like
a prostitute right
um this is also like he was also a
crackhead
this is like the even if he's of even if
it's full conviction
sixth worst thing he's done yeah it's
like to me
this is not hundred biden news
he's no [ __ ] that's who he is like i
don't know it's like
are you gonna go to a
houseless person that's clearly having
mental health issues and be like
he said like i don't know it just feels
like guys this guy has a lot going on
yeah texting true dat [ __ ] is not
the worst most defensive part of that is
true debt if we're honest
it's still using true debt that is the
real crime
and i wish the new york post would cover
that because for a
anyone in 20 what whatever year this was
it was after 1993. that's
to use true debt the n word fine
it's that's excusable what inexcusable
to me that's the high crime we have a
list now
judat uh dip set dip don't say dip set
when you're leaving
don't say dibs that's like what the
dealio is what the dealio
don't say what the billy which by the
way
wasn't even what he said he didn't say
what the dealio
what do you say he said what the dealy
comma
yo that's what he said thank you so much
uh scholars among us one of my favorite
hellos ever if i can
drop it like it's hot which is not a
charm which is a term that i
shouldn't have used what are you talking
about i'm trying to name drop
and i so uh i saw buster rhymes
hadn't seen boston rhymes in probably 17
years
six 15 years and i saw him and he goes
what up oh g
which is very funny just call me oj's
funny
oh g is good you are og i am og and the
fact that he's you know probably a five
percenter and doesn't
[ __ ] with white people like that was a
real felt real you know what bianca that
was a true dad
it was a true dad that was a true trudet
um so that's the real
trauma trauma of it is that people are
that a white guy is saying true that
again
not the worst part no actually
the worst part is not the n-word it is
the use of trudeau
well in the comment well i alright it
was easy for him to say
come on i can't it's hard to take it
seriously when it's all conservatives
trying to blaspheme
it's funny watching them try to try
stuff
and they're like let's try this it's
like someone looking for a new sound
like a band
we're like are we any let's try like
electronic
kind of like well let's do let's make a
dance record
like you're you too you don't [ __ ]
make dance records
well we're going to try it we hired the
we got the
we have the text number one
um uh yeah we've got the number one
um [ __ ] producer sorry i'm just
seeing some other news on there
what it would have uh to the right lower
right
right nope above it yep there we go um
riggy claims rob regal divorce problem
um so so yeah
who's really he's a comedian
son he was in the goods with jeremy
piven you know
closely personal funny funny dude he was
on the daily show he's in a lot of [ __ ]
he's in a lot of [ __ ] yeah
um he doesn't he's like a does like a
lot of commercials and
yeah he's like very hosting at this
point um
that's a page six story we're gonna stay
out of that yeah
uh where to stay yeah um so
anyhow um listen the other one above him
is
talks about your little thing oh yeah
we'll get to that so so
hunter i mean again name a white
crackhead
that doesn't say the n-word and i will
show you
somebody who's not truly addicted to
crack
okay it's also very funny for
uh white conservative media be like oh
of course
we look guys and everyone's like also
how do you get the text i mean it's like
one of these things
it's like why do you have these texts
how does this affect
the job joe biden's doing as the
president it doesn't they're just trying
to
they're just trying to hurt him there's
just a bunch of people who
say the n-word saying look at this
liberal
no they say urban they don't say the
n-word they just say uh urban
urban environment um some uh pocs
they don't um but they don't say whoa
you're it's of color now
since when i can't follow it yeah you
can you know what
anyhow um what happened to north
carolina well
hit it what these whites um this is all
what these websites this is all
this is all what are white people doing
so basically there was a a north
carolina plantation
had a celebration they went to celebrate
juneteenth
and they were going to do kind of like a
historical reenactment
and their white people were going to
have reenactment or black
that to people juneteenth to just kind
of take a look at
it said in the first paragraph so they
they were going to do
their event was promised to tell the
story of white refugees no it said
it said and i don't know where it is but
the ad says
come around and hear this hear
massa tell stories mass is hiding out in
the woods
because the reunion no who's the the
after him him and his white refugees
also have a story to tell white refugees
by the way kamal harris said they should
come dick please come
please please come um uh
if you can find the ad it's crazy
matt come listen to massa tell his tales
cause
white refugees have a story to tale to
here we go can you read them why
that's it odd you will hear stories from
the masa himself who is now living in
the woods
federal troops yankees have him on the
run and his former
bondsmans have occupied his home and are
now living high on the hog
hear how they feel about being freedmen
the overseer is now
out of a job what will he do now that he
has
no one to oversee from nor is he from
conceit to what will he do complain and
pretend he won
that's what he'll do based on if we're
basing it on history
from what i've seen for the last 140
years
60 he's gonna act like he didn't lose
and build statues and fly the flag
white refugees have been displaced and
have a story to tell
as well somebody made the observation
word that uh
the d-masking going
unmasked on in california so like that
june 15th 16th whatever it is is white
people's juneteenth
wow had to be just a few days before
it's white people's juneteenth finally
uh there were a bunch of comedians a
bunch of comedians oh comedians
and what's funny is like oh if a
comedian said it was but i thought
no it wasn't like it wasn't tucker
crossing a bunch of comedians and then i
was like well i guess the question is
who's going to tweet it
and then someone said that's more your
worst
so why don't you handle it they know you
so well they know my they know that i
love
i'm the one who came up with the
dominican goodbye so something
something to think about a dg thank you
so so much outrage they canceled can you
believe they canceled the event
they had to have it they had to be told
like
maybe fellas this isn't the right thing
to do i heard that they're going to do
next year a reenactment
of all the trouble they were in this
year
they're going to re reenact the whole
thing and the decision
mass is going to tell stories of how he
had to cancel the event
and it's going to be pretty fantastic
i'm way funnier this week than i was
last week
and you know why that is don't have a
head cold
i realized that really that was not
funny thank you and
of course shout out to plant medicine i
think it's plant medicine
uh you're loose you're nice well i'm
[ __ ] open apathy i'm the [ __ ]
empathy machine
um harvard did a study
about the blm protests and i don't want
to break
i don't want to give you the punchline
they so opponents characterize activists
as law breakers or as violent
when overwhelmingly they were
non-violent so they statistically they
were overwhelmingly non-violent
and most of the time it said there was
it was counter protesters that were
violent
yeah and police agitation
yeah and or truly false flags where
people
pretended to be blm and then brooke went
like in seattle there was a guy
and then he ran away yeah ran away i
mean he wasn't and he wasn't bombing
he just ran away to hide um
so that's the uh
i didn't i mean what's her that lady got
more trouble this week
patrice colors or mc patrice colors
she got in trouble for the one who was
building houses
the woman the blm oh yes she got in
trouble well first of all she left blm
yeah she left blm to focus on books and
tv
which um i'm not gonna i'm not gonna uh
comment on that i'm sure that
if anyone deserves has a fine sense of
narrative
storytelling and production it would be
a woman who worked in non-profits
now okay then she got in trouble for
uh for building a fence
it's a new york it's another new york
post gotcha and gotcha knockout didn't
get you
i don't get it's just you don't catch it
gotcha yeah
um don't got you gotcha they're gonna go
together
um so so yeah
she uh she got in trouble this week for
building it for we it
it's so funny how we're media wise
a lot of the stories hold anybody
associated
to like the upper level blm hold them to
the fire
more than like congressmen and women or
anything right you bought a house
wait a minute you bought a house
congress people
are known to be piece of [ __ ] that's the
thing it's
they're known to be a piece of [ __ ] it's
why comedians get in trouble instead of
congressman because like
well i i can't count on him for anything
right
you i can't affect mitch mcconnell at
all right i can affect
kevin hart and i will um i'm coming i'm
going to be on comedy gold mines
you mark my words kevin's podcast we
already recorded it it'll be out it was
actually good
really yeah when was it when's it i
don't know we recorded it
two weeks ago he does not stop working
and i know this because
we recorded he's in slovenia or
something filming a movie
and we recorded at like 3 30 in the
afternoon which
was like 3 30 in the morning his time
wow
and i didn't know that i just thought we
were having a conversation
you're also pretty busy i'm not that
busy
i mean he's like unbear i would hate it
yeah
all you need to know about kevin hart
being busy is that
his mother he grew up in a
shitty neighborhood his mother used to
schedule the [ __ ] out of him
and that's how he stayed safe lessons
classes
i'm signing up for this i needed for
that so once i heard that i was like
no i will say i will never not like i
was like
i'm gonna get him so hard for over
scheduling himself but it's sometimes
where
you're like why do you do all this [ __ ]
and it's because he just he can't not
right um anyhow uh
so blm was a non-violent movement we
tried to tell you
now the fbi did some [ __ ] that i liked
come on
and i you know that i love the game the
drug game the game um
so they had encrypt
they somehow leaked a bunch of encrypted
phones
criminals thought they criminals had
encrypted phones like
yo this is the new platform this is a
new ship like a what's up like uh but it
was
built into the phone okay like i think
it was probably thicker there was
something about it that made them think
that they were
uh safe phones and
they were the opposite of safe they were
all pre-encrypted
in a way that the fbi could only the fbi
and the person they were texting could
decrypt it
and it's pretty great again this is one
of those things where did you like the
game i know
i love the game but i like this part of
the game i like you
you know donnie brasco i you know i
don't i don't want the guy to become a
mobster
in deep cover i didn't you know what i
mean i love i like both sides of the
game that's why
eric about to do to bring it back to
bring it back uh to bring it back to bad
to
both sides of the game um very old
person
i am uh uh see curtis mayfield i'm like
i'm like uh eric michael dyson now
michael eric dyson yeah we're
quoting quoting curtis mayfield and mike
msnbc you're also quoting sponsors a guy
don't whoever
do you know eric michael does by side
well you can look it up but you or you
could
oh i know him you're gonna know him on
site
you know that you know him i do
yep so there you go i am old but i'm not
as old as him
although it's pretty close no actually
it's not no
15 at least 15 years that we know of
him and jay-z so close he wrote a book
about them and they took one picture
together
cool um so so what they so
so is that legal they yeah
they didn't make them take the phones
and it's like just encrypted and then
they get
they they probably re
like they i don't know if they
pre-subpoenaed or what but
i don't i don't mind it what do you
think
as someone who's so plugged into the
streets i mean
i
i don't know i'm kind of
this is similar to my i like how they
[ __ ] up the iranian nuclear program
through through uh algorithms
right it's like just like like oh that's
a good move yeah
like you're like um yeah good for you
that's fine yeah well played
you can't hate on a good on a good plan
[Music]
but for the for the episode i don't know
i'm both because it's like
federal investigation um
you're both yes because it's like [ __ ]
drugs and
uh like yes get that and [ __ ] law
enforcement and
[ __ ] and it's yes
again back to my statistics it's always
the little guys
we're not going after the big like big
drug busts
aren't as common as like just little
guys so i don't know for me i
it's just hard to i'm gonna lorry
lightfoot
my way out of this i like the espionage
version of it but
espionage is so it's difficult and we
like it we like
oh the pen turns into a it's a knife
uh yes but i don't but also
you don't want to be on it you don't
want to be unencrypted
unencrypted you don't want whatsapp to
magically
well yeah but there's also that thing
where they got some bitcoin ransom back
this week
yeah they did and that's one of those
things where it's like okay so is this
[ __ ] secure
i don't especially care right well they
probably just gave them access to their
[ __ ]
no what they bitcoin there is no them
no no no the pipeline the the bitcoin
they basically paid a ransom for the
pipeline right and then the fbi
got the money back right how oh how
that's the thing they didn't get it all
back they got certain
numbers basically they got certain you
know after a while
that [ __ ] goes i know that's where you
can because it's like oh we got a mine
these are numbers but they are so how do
you give them
and take them uh-huh it's wild this [ __ ]
is wild between these
encrypted phones and the blockchain
man it is so wild wow
um
uh tubing is back on cnn did you see the
segment
did we know it did we know what actually
happened so did he jerk off
he jerked off he basically my
understanding was
he they were on break right on zoom
right the problem with zoom is you have
to hit end call twice which i
do not like yeah it's like dawg just
you know i want to leave make it easier
for me to leave not harder
um he they were on break
right like we're gonna take a 20-minute
break he must have thought he muted it
or de-uh blocked the
turned his camera off he did not
he went to another computer and jerked
off
with somebody a gal on the other side of
the computer
she was jerking off also wow it's great
when it comes to
women when you say women are jerking off
they hate it a
and it's disgusting he's on a kevin
hart's schedule of he really isn't
freaking out he's the kevin hart of
masturbation
and i hopefully will be on his podcast
as well soon
and if we're recording it i don't want
to know what he's doing off camera
don't take a break yeah so
so then so then he so then on cnn he
goes you know
he came back i don't know if we're
allowed
yeah it's a little long gun violence
let's bring in cnn chief legal analyst
jeffrey toobin
to talk about this and more hi jeffrey
hello allison it's been a while
it has been a while indeed i feel like
we should address
um what's happened in the months since
we've seen you since some of our
viewers may not know what has happened
so
uh i guess i'll recap i'll do the honors
help yourself okay all right pause it
there was a punch line on help yourself
that you know right and
jeffrey that's how you got here in the
first place right helping ourselves is
why we're here in october
we were on a zoom call with your
colleagues from the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which
time you were caught masturbating on
camera
no you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn
do i have all that right um you got it
all right why
okay so let's start there um to quote
jay leno
what the hell were you thinking you guys
obviously i wasn't thinking very well or
very much
and it was something that was
inexplicable to me i think one point
i i wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't
think other people could see me you
thought that you had turned off your
camera correct
i thought that i had turned off the zoom
call now that's not a defense this was
deeply moronic and indefensible
but but
yeah it's what's indefensible about it
you jerked off
when you didn't think when you thought
you were allowed to jerk off
you and then and then it's it's uh his
behavior is inexplicable to him and then
she's like have you never
masturbated before like
what we're like crucifying this of
course but they
have to do this kabuki thing where they
go like walk the plank and he goes
i am so scared on the plank that's why i
think of letterman
when he had to apologize to his wife
yeah but his was
so low he just did his so uh
and the fact that he got away with it
and no one brings it up is pretty funny
it is pretty funny but that was
awkwardness it just it's well it had
laughter
that was the private letterman is people
would laugh and he used it to his
defense a couple of times but i you know
could okay
do you think there's a world where tuban
could have said
this is uh like done
done a gen z switch of like why am i
being shamed
for my normal for my kink i yes
i masturbate like yeah he absolutely
could have and i wish he had
it's so in her doubling that is
that should not have this is more
inappropriate than what happened
yeah this is him he might as well have
said
true dat go ahead this is the most
inappropriate thing i've seen since
trudet
the true dad texts that that is part of
the story
um and you know i have spent the seven
subsequent months miserable months in my
life i can certainly
confess i'm trying to be a better person
i mean in therapy
trying to do some public service um
working in a food bank which i certainly
am going to continue to do
working on a new book about the oklahoma
so he's working at a [ __ ]
food bank and writing an oklahoma city
bombing book
like like what is that i don't
understand
what that has to do old testament this
is just you
bad masturbator but the but
the reason it's happening is because the
people on the call the women on the call
were seem to be like
pretty outraged the thing is on the call
i feel like that totally
i could i could see someone being like
dude
like i do not it's a [ __ ] awful
it's like the worst thing that can
happen and we don't know what's going
with these ladies so i can
understand everybody on the call feeling
super violated
i don't know i would rather see someone
[ __ ] on my desk at work
than jerking off if i walked in
somewhere
if i'm on a work call i would
because there's nothing especially
graphic about your about uh
taking [ __ ] there's nothing graphic if
they're
squatted profile wise all all that's
different
is i'm seeing a lot of thigh and side
butt cheek
and maybe some poop i don't have to look
at their dick
i don't have to look at their master i
don't have to look at their jerking off
i don't have to look at any of it no so
i yeah so i think we're agreeing that
the for everyone who was who was
involved i
think this is appropriate give me 10
grand that's what that's what it should
be
just give them all 10 grand and you
don't have to go to a soup kitchen
food bank we're getting you have to
write a book about oklahoma city you
don't do any of this stay
out of like what i don't understand is
why we're owed anything in the audience
because everyone on tv is a [ __ ]
of course
so what yeah it's so it's such weird
justice
it's like that judge that makes you like
do you wear the sandwich board yeah
and he's fired from the new yorker he
has fired from the new yorker he worked
there for 27 years
i feel like he was in it every week he
wasn't but it was like he was the
top legal columnist in the new yorker it
feels like
ah just dirty laundry it's just
we all are yeah part of it was
they have to make an example of them and
it's like he didn't
jerk off against their will it wasn't it
was against their will
but he didn't it was an accident
if we're all on zooms it's like
you're seeing more of my house than
you've ever seen but there's been people
who
walked in the background naked of
someone's zoom yeah it's as
it's and they have to write a book about
the oklahoma city bombing now
and they have to work at food bank
that's just what
that's what happens that's what happens
um uh
and then hunter biden has to write a
book about cool herc
uh dj kohlherk it's an inside joke from
before the
broadcast we're talking about well i
just i don't know this feels
like just gross
it's grossly over it's just silliness
yeah
it's like it's it's kabuki silliness we
don't feel better as an audience
i don't actually want to think about
jeffrey tubin jerking off
could have just in turn it could have
just stayed in the yeah just like
like dog tuban the [ __ ] are you doing
now then they
when they wrote the articles about them
it was like he had a baby out of wedlock
with somebody's daughter and
did it and she was younger than him and
just it's like okay it's still
immaterial
the guy knows the law he's good at it
he's a
good enough tv broadcaster he had a baby
with someone's daughter
not yeah everyone's someone's daughter
overlapping i mean like his friend
not even his friend just another
journalist a guy who's kind of in
journalism
um and younger but not whatever like i
mean it's just once there's a thing it's
like
yeah forever also yeah so it's just a
fake
it's fake recrimination it's fake one
size fits all
when it's not it's like louis didn't
have to do this
yeah you know i mean he hasn't been
allowed back on cnn but
although yeah he has just not as a guess
uh the problem is that
cnn is has this
i don't know this fake like pillar of
morality yeah
so they can well they all have a fake
morality
i feel like foxes yeah but they're all
it's all in the name of jesus
of course i'm not saying cnn only i just
mean they all have these personalities
like
do you see this this is an apple yeah we
will
say it's enough yeah this is [ __ ]
right so
it's moralizing he didn't break did he
did he break the law
i don't think inadvertently getting
caught jerking off
first of all what has he gone through
imagine getting caught on a zoom we're
not even
jerking off i mean also how funny
poor jeffrey pray for jeffrey of course
how funny they should write the oklahoma
city
the people who caught up give them the
ones who should have been kicked off
in the new yorker i imagine the amount
of
i just i would love to hear the meetings
okay
what jeffrey's gonna come back but what
does he have to do
yeah i mean imagine the meeting yes
there's no
it's all silly they he's they also have
him under contract and if he gets fired
then he can sue him and did it
because if this is gonna happen again
well of course he's never gonna
[ __ ] he's you're not getting him on a
zoom he's not
everything's on the phone now landline
senator ray
on [ __ ] he's back to landlines um
jeffrey toobin back on landlines pray
for him
um oh this is a good one
the french the french open do you see
who won the french open
a lady where are they now the french
open who won
that name and that no not the other one
the women
right there
barbara do it ketchikova
may we just call them crutch
krejic krajiki kritikikova
and pavluchi pavluchen kardiki now i can
read cyrillics if this isn't surrealist
i'd be able to i don't know is
cyrillic's one of my favorite edm
um the um
so and he looks like corey feldman
cyril cyrillics skrillex i'm thinking of
skrillex i'm sorry
sweetie i'm sorry really yeah so my
point the point
i'm trying to make is you made the great
famous player leave for no
because you needed a [ __ ] dumb press
conference
and you know what you get in her place
the 31st seed
beat an unseated person the woman had
never played in a mate
meaning she's not even good enough to be
ranked so so it's just garbage it's just
like
okay maybe not go and well it's the 31st
player versus a player you've never
heard of
there's no people in her family haven't
heard of her that's how
not well-known she is i say that about
barbara brock karkalova
um uh a
kova um b cover a cup and b cover that's
what i got
um so yeah so okay cool
you guys won they did the press comments
it's all right
the only problem is no one asked them
any questions
because they don't give a [ __ ] about
them because ain't nobody watching the
tape
so this is where you get into the value
of stars
and i got a lot of pushback from the
clip last week a lot of dummies
with points of view yes yes uh when i
said that
that um yes that she was it was she was
it was great
and they were like she's gonna lose her
sponsors
they're not sponsoring her because she
does press conferences you [ __ ] dork
and they're not gonna sponsor the akova
ain't going to get it akova might get
like a shop in her
town b and she might need to get bikova
to do it with her just for like no dice
yes just for like just maybe some more
visibility
in case people don't recognize a cover
from the town
they'll go oh that's they seem together
i kind of recognize
they form a fairly recognizable person
um so the point is if you've got
this is why hollywood bends over
backward for stars
because uh it i can think of great
sketches all day
right if certain people aren't in them
it doesn't really make a difference it's
a [ __ ] funny or die video
yeah yeah i mean even but the only funny
or dive videos that work for the once it
starts
so like this is why this is the thing
like what's the difference between
um you know spell show and
neil write a bunch of sketches i'll give
you a hint
names in the title it's just different
if you can get someone that people like
to watch
inherently to do the thing instead of
like
well yeah but then we have things that
we need why do you need it
right we cause we decided and we've been
doing it for a long time and yeah we are
the
correspondents that cover this thing and
that no one wants to budge
yeah it's like when a star is late uh
like i'll do commercials sometimes um
where they'll go so-and-so would like to
be done by two
and um but i'm i have to get shots till
4 30. right you're like
and i go and i go uh just someone i go
okay
because what am i going to do it's like
or okay
or we can replace them okay not kevin
hart and chase
not replaceable literally not [ __ ]
replaceable
like i mean but there's nobody that hits
all the quad
even if you think about maybe the rock
maybe i mean the rock yeah not maybe
definitely
rock's the most famous person in the
world and like the most beloved
but what if the rock's late eating right
right you don't get the close-up right
yeah but you take the 4k image and you
blow it up to a close-up
and that's how you shoot celebrities
bianca right
so if you so you didn't get i hope
you're happy friendship i hope you're
happy and now is anybody
talking about the fact that like it went
what do you think not really i mean they
can't espn can't talk about it
nobody's on her side that's
in that's in media that covers sports
because it they have to be on the
the institutional side so you know
it's like they're never on you know a
guy who wants a trade or a guy
you know and again i don't think it's
a par i think it's a part of their
it's part of their job
to me if guys do interviews after
playoff games or championship games in
the nfl
in the i mean what's his name got so i
don't get fined um right
cam newton got in trouble because he
kind of sulked through his interview
he got in trouble i mean he got fined or
he got like
dinged like people were like that was
uncool dude respect that yeah
but if there and don't want to be there
it's a bad interview
yeah straight up i got another name drop
seth meyers one time told me the thing
you learned at snl was
if if a star doesn't want to do the
sketch
they're not doing it you can't force
them
you can't go come on it's so they don't
they're not comfortable doing it and it
won't be it will not
be good and it will not be picked like
how do you want me to [ __ ] this up
not even like they're they're tossing
right they're like throwing the fight
they just aren't good at that kind of
accent
there's somebody who i won't say who it
was but
seth wrote a sketch got an australian
accent it's i'll tell you off-camera
it's not even like juicy it's just like
oh
australian accent and the guy goes i
don't
do a good australian accent and seth was
like
what like but you do what shitload of
voices how can you not and then
and then he realized that a lot of
showbiz is about managing your talent
and like what can i do well right let me
just do that
even if it means doing less like i just
do that well i'll just do that well my
little [ __ ] corner
instead of going like i'll try it okay
and then you look like a [ __ ]
there's a reason why i mean
not every actor or performer whatever
can do everything
and when they do those are the movies
that flop
and we don't hear that ahead of time we
don't hear about them they know that
ahead of time a lot of the time
and then people get or they get gassed
up and they go like i can do yeah i can
do i am i can do when someone told flex
he could do michael jackson
flex alexander yeah did you see that
made from the movie no where flex was
michael jackson
no flex ass michael jackson
you don't remember that [ __ ] wow
wow you don't remember that
it was too good that's a wild time
it was that's a wild time it's not
halloween oh it's so funny
um anyways anyhow so yeah no so
yeah like but d okay question is a
sketch funny
you write a sketch you need the person
do let's say he's a famous person
austrian accent is it funny if they
do a bad australian accent or is that
kind of like a little too
no it's bad in fact i won't say who i
did a commercial with
and they i said hey do it this way and
they did it that way a bunch of times
and the minute they did it it was
unfunny
and they gave it the old college try and
then they were like let me do it again
let me do it without that
and it was like oh yeah what am i why am
i i was like
i meant to apologize to them because it
was like just stupid why am i like why
am i for i
i didn't fight for it i was like ah
maybe you'll do it better maybe you're
not doing and then
and then it was like oh no it's just one
of those things he can't do
sketches are better when everyone's
doing them
the best possible way i'm not a fan of
big
like teeth and wigs and it's just hacky
yeah
um anyhow that's that's all for today
what's that
twice the amount that's why this not
like we have we don't connection please
talk about
diarrhea oh diarrhea there was a
diarrhea
thing outbreak outbreak on
uh
uh ultimate slip and slide television
show
there's a lot to this story guys there's
a lot explosive
diarrhea this is a true dad n-word
situation because i don't know what's
crazy
there there's a slip and slide
competitive tv show
or the fact that up to 40 crew members
fell
violently ill on set um
a source with knowledge of the
production said an outbreak of quote
awful explosive diarrhea unlike the
non-awful
explosive diary led to people collapsing
on set
and being forced to slip and slide into
porta-potties
no being forced to run into port-a-potty
oh giardia
that's that's the like bad traveler kind
yeah
somebody uh it's they got g-a-r-d-i-a
guardia g giardia whatever you want to
call it gif or jif
no one knows um and
scroll plays well and uh it's of course
posted by ron funches which is fantastic
i hope he didn't either he didn't get
infected they probably were like don't
you [ __ ] say a conflict
no well the funny thing was on some of
the i texted ron because
there was a there was like outbreak on
set and it's a picture smiling around no
so it sounds like he had something
terrible um and uh and
yeah so and just a picture of you with
explosive diarrhea right
just pretty satisfying um and they're
airing it
during after the closing ceremony of the
olympics which is like
okay if you guys think that's what
if it's that serious i think fantastic
well
we'll not be returning to its original
i would like to say something which is
i'm and i don't want to get into this
very specifically
i'm pretty diarrhea lucky
that's all i'm gonna eat well i'll tell
you something that i we won't get into
but
i pray for diarrhea every day of my life
i love diarrhea and i like having it
it's easy
it's easy in out you don't just you know
what you did you genzied me
on diarrhea i saw it as a negative no
it's a positive
it's a pot don't just don't
i like it i don't ever have it and when
i do i'm like
well that's like and i don't again we
don't need to get into it i know about
that but when you're a little kid
and you're so dehydrated that you almost
never have to wipe
i don't know if you remember that period
of your life but where you just it's so
you're so dehydrated that it's all just
like yeah i don't know why do we even
have toilet paper
i never need it anyhow that's i don't
yeah he doesn't like i'm actually
surprised you
went as far as i went because you don't
like i don't like it well you know now
now to just reel it back
uh that's why there are those signs
at pools do not come in the pool if you
have diarrhea
because it's contagious the guard the
giardia
guardia giardia and rotavirus
which is another one noro norovirus
maybe that's a computer thing
but no there's a one that sounds like
rotavirus
anyways there's these ones so if you
have any type of
loose bowels stay out of the pool
i like that they uh they're implicitly
with that sign going you can pee a
little
oh they're just talking about a certain
type of stool if you're gonna take like
a [ __ ]
it's fine and you're gonna pay alone
it's fine but diary can we talk about
diarrhea
i have a i have a i have a useless
observation go
loving it her first her first
uh if you're in a pool with a lot of
people
everyone's assuming someone's probably
people right
and you're still swimming well because
you can't prove it
or disprove it if someone stood outside
the pool and took a piss
in the pool everyone would like throwing
hands
we're throwing hands it's gonna be a
wild scene it's gonna be the guy who
beat up the
it's sons and four same amount of people
i'm popping i'm getting me a headlock
sun's in four
i'm beating the [ __ ] if you don't know
what i'm talking about a guy at the
utah phoenix game on
friday or saturday beats
uh two two utah fans tried to sucker
punch a guy
they did the thing where they acted like
it was done you can play it it's pretty
great
all right so the fight's over they're
ready to go like we're done we're done
we're done we're done we're done we're
oh [ __ ] you oh gosh and then he tries to
fight him again
and then here he goes bang bang bang
bang
light work he wants him to clean shot
while he has the other guy
i'm gonna [ __ ] your boy up i'm a [ __ ]
boy up uppercut
it just sends it and then he says suns
and four at the end
what does that mean he that the sons are
gonna beat
utah in four games which they then
before they
did he's a problem i said that he's a
psychic but he can only do readings
if he's beating the [ __ ] out of you i
understood what you meant at the
beginning of the
episode but now you see we see um this
is actually pre the episode this is
this is we talked about that before we
did suns and four is now
and really it's a it's a hashtag it's
very effective hashtag
and like i said it's i said it's
he's a psychic but he can only give the
reading if he's beating the [ __ ] out of
you and then someone tweeted underneath
it
punch punch punch your grandma's gonna
be fine
which is a great joke also it's suns and
four is something that's
that's not because you know you always
say whatever you're famous for people
yell at you
yeah sons before he's good something for
the rest of his life
it's fantastic like that's what they're
gonna he might as well change his legal
name
to something for it's like to remember
temecula
made me in temecula no wait what there
were two guys
chirping on on um
chirping on twitter about how they were
gonna [ __ ] each other up
they were chirping about kobe okay and
then finally one of the guys
ended it with meep me and temecula which
is just the funny
like but he meant it like i'm gonna
fight you in temecula
but then it became a whole thing and
then the guy one of the guys actually
drove
me amazing regulars it's the
it's the the sons and four of 2014.
um anyhow diarrhea
rest in power don't rest in power king
uh bianca's looking for you
binky bianca is looking for
to get into it with you um
[Applause]
whale guy got swallowed by a whale yeah
bianca
the whale man the whale man also found
out
he's like dodged death like ten times
he's a he dives for oysters apparently
uh second dive of the day
he's a lobster diver lobster yeah there
we go um
and i like that everything's got like i
don't do it with cages i do it by hand
um and he got swallowed by a whale
apparently
and he was the whale closed his mouth
at one point the guy said all of a
sudden i felt this huge shove
and the next thing i knew it was
completely black
um terrifying i could sense i was moving
and i could feel the well squeezing some
with the muscles in his mouth
that's terrifying if i don't want to
feel the inside of a person's
mouth i was completely i mean certain
certain saucy gals i was completely
inside it was completely black i thought
to myself
there's no way i'm getting out of here
i'm done i'm dead
all i could think of was my boys they're
12 and 15. aren't they always
they're always that no one ever goes i
can only think of my boys they're
29 45. um
after a certain point they stop thinking
of you on their deathbed it's sad it's a
sad point
um and
[Music]
yeah and then out he had scuba gear how
do we know it's true the whale began
shaking its head so that
uh so he knew he didn't like it he
didn't like it
very much having the human uh he
estimated he was in the whale for 30 to
40 seconds
before the whale finally surfaced i saw
a light and he started throwing his head
from side to side
and the next thing i knew i was outside
in the water didn't taste
and then a second whale came and
happened okay uh that's
uh i don't believe the 30 to 40 seconds
part
it's a long time that's a long time you
can last
you can technically i mean he's a diver
so
but he's probably it probably felt like
that maybe it was less
yeah i believe him more than you though
yeah that's pretty pretty exciting and i
don't have much to add to it other than
um that whale did the right thing
and he's gonna be he's gonna be uh
he's gonna be rewarded for it in whale
in the whale world um
yeah it reminded me of wasn't it
pinocchio well it's the the
the story of jonah in the bible oh god
in the way and the whale
you don't know about jonah and the whale
it's like the the bible's got like five
famous stories that's one of them
tell me tell me daddy i don't even it's
uh he gets swallowed by a large fish and
he spends three days and three nights
which again everything in the bible's
three days and three three days three
nights thirty seconds
it's like uh it's like vacations on
dating game shows
um three day usually it's three days two
nights and uh and then he prayed to god
and then um god tells
the fish to vomit jonah that's pretty
much everything that's the bible
that's just story check jonah's story
checks out yeah
so um it happened and um
you know i wonder if this guy will
believe in god more
we'll see might need a little ayah i
might need a little something for you
guys for you it's called medicine
um i have a uh but mine is
mine is as anybody see this they're
they're betting on supersonic travel
i feel like it what do you mean with uh
with bezos and everybody
uh united oh yeah they're going back to
that
they're going back to the concord the
old uh concord
people that are old me and eric michael
eric dyson used to fly it all the time
you can get it's it shaves
the it shaves the time off it shaves
like
la to london like three hours from yeah
it becomes a three-hour
flight and what do you think
i don't think it's a big enough
improvement
it's 10 hours
i don't it's not 10 hours to london yeah
yeah
new york to london no no i'm sorry la to
london okay well that doesn't make la to
london three hours
la to london on it's 10 hours you're
correct
uh supersonic 347.
neil i'm correct we're gonna round up
we're gonna talk about
four and everybody knows it um
although that may be the black in you
when you say
you're gonna be somewhere in three hours
it really means three hours and 47
minutes and black people you know i'm
right about this
um again inventory i guess
um uh this benefits us
uh yeah i don't yes i don't
i'm not going to pay more for that you
know that just it feels like it'll fall
apart in the air
you know what it looks like it looks
like uh the skinny dick that no one
likes
it's no one likes a woman no one likes a
skinny no one likes a skinny dick um
it doesn't care it's 12 inches yeah but
that's not the whole story
it's not it's a you're do you got a fire
poker in your pocket
and apologize um so
i don't that's one of those things
that's going to cost 15 grand
yeah it'll be nice and i have virtually
nothing to gain
by saving uh
seven hours we're gonna go with your
time seven hours 6 45 but
um it's actually 7 45 but but it's gonna
i don't need i like planes because i
like sleeping now
that may change once i fix my binocular
dysfunction but
yeah you may not i may not sleep i may
not just instantly pass out on planes
right but then you'll be able to enjoy
the the amenities
finally i mean i've been rich for too
long
do they still give is that still
something
do they still are the amenities still
exciting i know you know what i do with
the amenity i whole i do save them all
and i use them for the chapstick the
whole thing just for the chapstick
chapstick
and uh occasionally houseguests and i'll
let them use a brush
from one of my you know put on the
pajamas
no never never have can you save the
pajamas like that
would you like them i like them may have
some upstairs
i don't but i i do have the sheets i'm
kidding
um
i don't have a dock watch i watch that
show hacks you know that show has it's
really good it's
all over i know i
was a little skittish because i don't
like when they
do comedians and tv shows we all just
look like sweaty monsters
and there's a bit of sweaty monster but
the girl who plays the young writer
woman her name's hannah hannah and
binder
hannah einbinder um is good and they
have a good relationship
and of course mike sure produced it and
i didn't even realize it
yeah um and uh it's
just good it's like one of these the
episode i was very
main gene smart here we go the i was
very
impressed with the writing it was like
as well done as it could have possibly
been
there's a argument between the two of
them that
they wait they could have done it way
sooner yeah
and they wrote like an extra page and a
half
before they did the blow up and it was
like that's good [ __ ] writing
question because when i see things
even like for some reason i've gotten
into game of thrones when i like
don't nearly have the time to watch it's
about time
right behind you right behind you right
now all quarantined
now every i i i i've
taken everything in me not to address
you as my lord
i want to say my lord and my lord
but i'll see one
you know half a line like a under five
i'm like they auditioned 500 people for
that
so it takes you out of it just just on
the acting side of things when you're a
writer does it
does it take you out of a good show
because you know like
oh funny that they put that there or
like you should
currently you can do it
it's like anything where you're doing it
and you're also like oh
like if you if you're driving you're
like traffic's bad you don't like swerve
off the road no of course
you just like but you know more than the
average watcher
yeah ostensibly i would also like to say
that sure
isn't sure is the producer and the
writers are jen statsky
paul downes and uh
lucia and yellow paul downs and lucia
wrote for
broad city and and
jen satsuki wrote for a bunch of shirts
shows and
she worked i worked on her with
something she's cool
so you liked it you liked the stuff yeah
um
yeah it was good it was just like i'm
not gonna i don't think i'm gonna watch
anymore because i don't
i was curious but i don't know if i'm
not like i gotta see where these
character i'm just like all right that's
okay good yeah good i watched a show
called
mayor of east town yeah people like that
one it's not good
okay guys like i don't know who these
people are
yeah um it's a show about a murder but
of course we need everyone needs a
storyline
right most of them go nowhere they're
just like
character building but to to
nowhere yeah um it's like i
i don't understand how people there were
two episodes where
nothing happened and she's drab and
is miserable and has bad energy but
somehow everyone wants to [ __ ] she's
doing a philly accent right
she's yeah i actually thought it was
mass somewhere
it's philly philly yeah uh
you know when people do that like home
yeah sort of east coast thing it was
like that's philly
that is phil yeah oh interesting yeah
yeah
yeah
okay i live there and i you're
thankfully i didn't pick it up thank god
she doesn't guys i i could have done
chicago i could have done philly
i went for neither because i knew on
standard american sight that they were
bad they were
not they were they they were not great
accents um the
acting is all great in it but the the
show is
sorry it's not good and it's slow
everyone somehow wants to [ __ ] this lady
who doesn't
try and is uh bad energy and not
pleasant to be around
yeah okay yeah i just i didn't i didn't
like it just was a lot of eye rolling to
me and then
she looks like a dowdy kate winslet
weird that's the they're like you look
like a downy kate onesie
um i have a great burn and a name drop
come on
this is a big name to update yeah um you
know how vince vaughn
used to be incredibly good looking
so good looking it was like confusing
if you look at kirk if you look at vince
in
swingers you're like you can't what the
[ __ ]
his cheekbones he's so old he looks
he's better looking than james dean oh
and [ __ ]
funny like really like with a
personality and improv
funny right then he got fat
then he got skinny again
and when i saw him skinny again that's
cruel will that's a tough one
when he got skinny again he gets skinny
again yeah
he's friends with steve byrne he was any
hung out at comedy clubs all the time
yeah and i go i go vince he got skinny
again i go vince you look great you look
like a young vince vaughn
it's a good part um anyhow
that's i deserve it that was good it was
good it hurts it really
gives you a sense of how badly i need it
right um
yeah just like yep i need it um
let's do some mails
[Music]
i bought some [ __ ] [ __ ] that ain't
work dumb purchase
dumb perch i bought some [ __ ] [ __ ]
that ain't
the music bad she was back up camera two
stunned guns in the hands free falls in
minneapolis
fridge water burger salt pad like
electric school
i got all this [ __ ] and i don't want to
use it
that's good that's good that's very good
fog labs thank you fog laps
these are blaze pods
right they light up
and basically i saw it on drive to
survive the formula one show
right that these things light up
there i guess i'll light them up light
them up light that [ __ ] up okay
i gotta get on the app the blaze app app
um they're the blazepot app tell me what
they do
they light up and you basically oh like
hit it
whack it slap it yes yes but what is the
point of it
uh exercise planks
[Music]
oh when you're on a plankton yeah planks
you can do running you can
set them up for the kids basketball um
i mean you know you like um
they're called dumb purchases for for a
reason um
[Music]
we didn't get as much usage out of them
as we thought we would
he did i'm not doing as many planks as i
planned
that's on me i planned
it was summer planks um
and i didn't get the amount that i
wanted and that's on me all right
they're lighting up now they're lighting
up
oh they're lighting up they're lighting
up gangplank they're lighting up okay
dumb purchase pod number four is about
to be done
that's really good that's a very good
song
okay here we go let's light them up okay
oh they're lighting up so you'll be in a
plank and then you
oh
that's from plank position you hit these
yeah that's this one
and then whatever and then you do other
things and the next thing you know
you're broken dead
next thing you know you're out of mind i
took a directive um so
but that's the dumb purchase the blaze
pod
no no no no just blaze parts
blaze pot i'm just gonna keep saying it
that was a dumb person we mostly did
that for the song and hopefully will
will cut out the boring parts and by
the boring parts i mean all of it
go ahead you've got mayo quick question
for bernardo and bianca
my rescuers get it um yes
i do the satan asking how was your week
has inspired me you two switch bodies
right
male female poc white men
uh how was your week ready go thanks
love you guys bye
oh if we switch bodies it would be like
yeah i'd be like just jerking it off
like i've been meaning to get in this
thing for a while
i'm finishing your joke you just thought
i would grab your boobs
it don't end there as well you would
look at them and you'd be [ __ ]
jerking off
like on a zoom i got to get on a zoom so
i can jerk off i would just be like as
neil you would i would be i'd freaky
friday though
yeah oh your personality that's that he
didn't exactly say that
but he's just assumed oh what would i do
um i guess i would try
to put myself in as many scenarios as i
possibly could
well that doesn't do it either because i
was going to try to get a woman's point
of view on things
like let me just try to understand yeah
what a woman would think in this
situation
and then like what is it like if i wear
cleavage but there's two i don't like
the attention
like i intentionally wore cleavage
and then was put off by the amount of
guys mentioning it
because that to me is i don't understand
what that would be like
as an example well i mean as a guy does
there's a four
i'm sure there's seven there is it is
hard though because
like i have big boobs so it's really
hard to
like wear everything and
you not have cleavage it's not like yeah
you know
i don't have to like tape them down or
something yeah and i and which i would
have done in the first hour just to
see it just to do it because i love tape
on auditions because
sometimes because they stick out in
front of me
um when i self tape i put i wear like
two sports bras
because they don't yeah like it just
looks like this big titty [ __ ] wants to
be
um so and even then it's very
hard to get around so uh it's not that
i'm gonna intentionally wear this
cleavage and then i'm going to be like
no
but i don't know right i don't even
think i
it's i i don't think it's like i'm going
it's
there's something in you whether it's
like as simple as like
you're ovulating that weird [ __ ]
like when women ovulate they show more
skin statistically
okay um it's statistically i just i'm
just trying to understand
so and then men tip them more just weird
[ __ ] like that that neither
party controls right so what would
that if i do something
and it i don't want to talk about
accidentally i'm talking about
specifically like
i need attention and then i need sexual
attention
and then if i get it i don't like it
[ __ ] like
that's how you guys i can't really do
much
to get sexual attention without being a
douchebag i think the difference is
at some point as women you
like at whatever age you realize and
it's an early age
that doesn't take much i don't have to
wear a shirt
yes i have looked funky
study of female universities found that
female university students found that
they astute
drab clothing for a more flamboyant
style when they were ovulating
suggesting hormonal changes had an
unconscious effect on their behavior the
women were not necessarily dressing more
provocatively
we did see a bit more skin that's cool
so yeah
so [ __ ] like that where i'm doing stuff
unconsciously
i'm getting that's getting a response
that i don't like
and then how do i because as a guy i
would just go i'm [ __ ]
it's like if i'm wearing a watch i'm
gonna get robbed
so i would immediately go to that
whereas i don't think women go to that
as a as a as a
natural uh line of things well one
i mean it's not like life is a at
every corner rapist you know what i mean
but i don't mean rapist i just mean
well you know capcom uh the thing is
and i think it's hard sometimes for guys
to understand
the limits guys will go i've worn
i mean a sweatpants tucked into cowboy
boots
with a sweater on i'm rocking my heart
as hell i'm hard as hell
and it's still like edgar yeah
there's no limit you know there's no
actual way to
and then um i remember me and my friend
when we were teenagers
she started feeling i thought i couldn't
get any harder
she started feeling fly and she wanted
to
borrow my friend's tube top to go to a
part of town that wasn't like great
wasn't it tube top friendly it wasn't a
tube top friendly i won't describe why
but
uh no tube tops i would not have worn a
tube top to this part of town
we had to go because we were going to
this thing whatever
and um when i tell you as soon as it was
nightfall
bianca's this is how bianca stops white
people from weaponizing racism
go ahead i tell you nothing
um as soon as it hit nightfall
i was she was like i will tell you
she never she never wore tiptup again
you know
and that was a lesson learned at 15. so
you do have these
you touch the stove moments as a woman
and
i mean after a certain age we know what
we're doing kind of
not like we know what we're doing but we
i know when i feel comfortable
dressing somewhere i know when whatever
i get attention i get attention i
i see it as i like showing off my body
when i feel like showing off my body
and if male attention comes with it
good or negative i mean it is what it is
that's just my outlook
yes but i think there are some i it
seems like there are women that
are not aware of the part
that they play in the negative attention
i guess it's because we have this false
sense of freedom in this country it's
just like well why can't i just wear a
summer dress that
that makes just me feel good yeah
not about you or getting attention i
just feel
great in this dress i worked hard or i
worked off my body whatever i don't know
and i have to also think about random
ass
dudes at every corner and them making me
feel uncomfortable you know like
that is a thing that i don't think you
can fully understand
and i don't think that's fair no i don't
and i don't think that's but if you wear
a lot it's like
there are male versions of it that like
am i going to have to stop at a gas
station
maybe don't wear this there's little
danger looks
for everybody danger lurks and i think
the
problem is from a male to female
relationship it's just confusing because
you could walk the same road 1000 times
and be cool i think a guy will know when
he can't wear a watch and when he can
right and with a woman there is always a
pop go
a jack-in-the-box moment where like you
could be the safest
and you could still get raped or taken
advantage of or this person is your
friend
and then one moment they're not your
friend anymore so
it's just a harder it's just a harder
thing to have full command of you know
what i mean yeah
of course but that's what i'm trying to
master
as a weekend woman yeah
long time listener unfortunately do not
remember the acronym at the moment so my
bad on that
stop it [ __ ] this guy
um i wanted to write in regarding neil
stett
a couple weeks ago regarding uh the
you guys having the largest number of
multiracial listeners of any podcast
which as one myself i tend to agree with
but i think the issue is
not being able to tie that to any real
data
which obviously not just for you guys
but i think overall
right the structural limitations whether
it be the census not allowing you to
check multiple boxes
or you know studies conducted around
race being very specific along
you know distinct racial groups there's
just really not much data
around multiracialism but i do think as
we've seen the social justice movement
unfold it's done so sort of episodically
with us right now being on stop asian
hate
so maybe in later seasons we may have
you know some focus on
folks with multiple racial identities
and um really the nuances of having to
navigate that
um so i wanted to get your thoughts see
what you guys think excited to hear it
um also want to throw out there that
banks if you are
ever in new york city anytime soon i
would be honored to
take you up for a drink and neil please
don't make fun of me too much for that
last part
i mean it's bianca yeah i got to take a
swing this guy's
half white half black and half
long-winded
and uh he is mixed full hot do you think
is that hot
even with the jew good for him he's cute
he looks like he looks like what drake
he looks like ezra edelman
no he doesn't he does ezra looks like
this with a haircut
more or less i mean again nobody people
don't like when you
ezra wouldn't be happy to hear it and he
wouldn't be having to hear it like
nobody's happy but face shape it's
similar
he just has a deep voice i'm a sucker
for a deep
um uh yes hi good for him
well if you ever if you ever get to new
york city it's going to be supersonic
guys or she's not going
the train comes um
i kind of like kind of
zoned out on his question well it was
too long that's again that's going to
happen on the date
the thing that people the mistake people
make is they tell you
everything they know about something and
just tell them
just give me the headline and i'm as
guilty as anyone but
that's why i have a podcast well also
you are very good at
you're good at like uh
i run away and you're right away and you
organize information
in a pleasant way not everybody has that
skill i have a friend who when she meets
someone
it's a information bomb yeah it's like
well you know i was actually do it for i
mean
to the point where i'm like yeah and
there's that's one of those things
there's nothing you can do
you can't you can't explain that to her
you gotta
lay it but it's not good you need to
learn how to lay
information out it's very difficult to
explain it it's like
grade school it's yeah i think it's a
primal thing it's very hard to undo that
you
lay information out nice and
if someone throw yes ands your
information you're like okay cool and
you can go off that so that's about as
good of storytellers
as you're gonna hear uh no i hope that
that guy i don't know what to
make of the mix he's complaining that
there aren't more
mixed statistics there was also a br of
uh [ __ ] there weren't enough
dark-skinned
latin afro-caribbean people in the
heights a woman complained
and confronted the director and claimed
that her daughter was
more uh crushed or just some like
hyperbole
and they're still going to be
good-looking people
the problem is we may change beauty
standards
symmetrical eyes nice lips nice layout
is still
going to be the name of the game the
the problem is though and there's a real
problem of the whitewashing of
latin culture yeah which is why when i
say i'm afraid i love j-love go ahead
which is why when i say afro-latin
people want
literally up until a few years ago don't
know what the [ __ ] that was
what afro latin did you
think because they had white white
passing
features do you think you have white
features
i don't know that seems like a slippery
slope i i'm
uh well but you know what i mean that's
what that was part of the complaint
which is like okay
so you're asking for your
it just gets pretty close to measuring
stuff
for sure but there are i think when you
think of latin america we think of jlo
and sophie regatta and that's it and
we don't are there are there others go
ahead
like for example uh zoe's aldonna for
example she's
she's avalon she has
not white features you know right which
is why she's always playing green people
exactly she hasn't played a while she's
never played two decades crossroads yeah
since
oh boy did i tell you the woman who
directed
uh half bank directed crossroads right
after it really yeah
wow i got some backward yeah that's one
of those things where it's like
that seems lateral um and
uh i have some good uh britney scoops
from 1998 you guys right i don't
i don't have any i'm not gonna share
them on the pod they're not
like shareable no i mean they're not
they're benign but they're just boring
um but yeah no so we don't have
like these there's so many
black looking people in latin america
there's so many you can't believe
and even there's a lot of colombians in
panama when i lived in panama
the most beautiful women i've ever seen
were dark-skinned women from a place in
colombia called kali
they were they looked like barbies they
were just barbies with
a very dark skin and so
neil's hand is doing something if i'm
not mistaken it sounds like we're
talking about
sea stuff i
could be mistaken we callie callie has a
cartel
kelly has a great but anyways basically
like i don't know it just feels like
we are still stuck in half the
[ __ ] in new york i mean you
lived in new york yeah
dominicans look black a nightmare i'm
kidding black nightmare
they do they want to they no dominicans
look truly look they're
black dudes you say what's up and they
go hold on you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah and i'm sorry uh dominican republic
the other half of the island is haiti
i know somehow they're not black some
are they well that's very separate whoa
yeah that is we are not this way well by
the way that's kind of how the dr
handles it but
that's a whole lot that's a whole other
issue yeah we don't have that we
don't got the bandwidth for that we
don't that's a separate podcast
haitian dominican republic good luck
figuring that out it's like they might
as well be brennan's it's so complicated
goodbye you've got mail ola
nardo oh my god there you go i'm in a
classroom so don't mind the ac
but one of my favorite things that neil
does on the podcast
is basically just try to surmise
a person's career and by just saying i
don't
know which i think is hilarious but
i became a fan of podcast through your
show and another show called blank check
and they discuss directors filmographies
and right now they're discussing the
filmography of john singleton so he's a
director who like obviously had talent
but
he kind of became this figurehead for
people who just turned into functionary
film
directors in hollywood at that time and
so this one's for neil but what do you
think is the reason why some directors
do that why some directors just go from
making
extremely personal things to just making
hollywood
[ __ ] i mean depending on if you think
that's [ __ ]
but let me hear what you think um neil
you're a beautiful and tender man
and i don't want you to ever think
you're not beautiful and bianca you're a
lady and a scholar
and one of the smartest people i've ever
heard talk so
thank you very much a committed tuesday
listener good evening
well that's nice i did it right right
did it right he was
tonally from beginning to end yeah hola
good evening sons and beautiful sons and
four sons and four
um you didn't you know john a little bit
um
i was on snowfall yeah he was very nice
to me very
warm welcoming saw me cross like yaga
yeah come here like immediately as i
walked on set
very lovely um that was the
round one snowfall with lauren london
kofi uh lots of great people did we shot
it
hey everyday fired us all reshot it so
there you go you showed them
could have been i mean that's famous but
that's it's also in season three people
like it
were they right to fire those people
like that's one of those things you'll
never know
i don't know lauren london killed it so
i believe it
they just probably i don't know did they
rewrite it or they just reshot it
so from what i understand it was not the
acting because like kofi no kofi
no the like attractive guy he was in
girls trip
the dark-skinned co-founders i'll just
imagine boris kid joe
yeah dark skin boris kofi girlship
um and uh from what i understand
he's like okay he's just like an
extremely attractive man yep
um so from what i understand it
had to do with uh he's one of these guys
that's great looking
and then if he's somewhere outside and
one dude goes why is i
so close together he doesn't get laid
that day
because he's his eyes are a little close
together that it's
he's still great looking but if someone
says it
it ruins it for the for for a day
i don't know he gets in his head
later he's it's just one of those things
great looking
he's so hot but if somebody says uh
why is i so close together like loud in
a group
it's gonna get a huge laugh okay it's um
it's like the old tracy ross somebody
said yeah
tracy ross i'd hate to date trade this
is
there's like there was a barbershop show
on vh1 or something in the
o's yeah and and uh it's terrible
somebody
not the sitcom it was a it was a real
like a reality show because
everyone the might it just wasn't sound
was bad
oh okay yeah you're probably right one
guy said i wouldn't want to date tracy
ross
because i'd always think i'd always
think someone was sneaking up behind me
which once you hear it very hard
not to not to think about what you're
saying
your trace is the best and pattern her
hairline very good
it's she's she's doing good with that
pattern's fantastic
great uh but so from what i understand
john was doing a a
tv pilot on a on a movie budget and it
was just there was just a lot
going wrong from what he told me and um
uh i was promised that footage i
promise i ain't giving you no no i'm
never getting
no he was he told me i could have it but
whatever uh the point is that
i think there was so much [ __ ] with
that first round
there was like so much going on and they
couldn't clear
certain i don't know i think it was
easier to just like read
redo but i can speak to the director
the personal part or the why make
personal stuff versus
commercial stuff because it's way first
of all
baby baby boy is a [ __ ] weird movie
by anyone's by his own admission
um and it's easier to make
it's easier to get hired on fast and
furious
than it is to get to start baby boy
from your script that you're fighting
for and they're going what
tyrese and ving rhames and snoop like
he he butt naked headlock
it's just a lot of weird [ __ ] and then
but then if you go
right what do you mean i mean he made it
sound like his filmography uh descended
into
nonsense whereas it just it descended
into four brothers
um abduction okay abduction
whatever yeah it it it it it develops
badass i thought that was uh bam peoples
i thought it was top i think it was i
think he's producer
um so you just get into it's just
easier hey the other thing that people
people have family they get married and
they
either have to support their family
yeah or their divorce they have to they
need they need
spousal support they need money whenever
someone's doing some [ __ ]
it's they need money they've probably
just got divorced you realize
gig works yes everybody even kevin hart
is on gig work yes
i mean yeah i mean uh chris baby was the
last thing he wrote because it's
too [ __ ] hard to get weird [ __ ] made
and then furious
four brothers abduction um and it's just
easier it's they're ready they have a
start date
and an amount of money you're gonna make
on too fast too furious
we you will have 800 grand in your bank
account by
june 30th so you just go i don't know if
you give a [ __ ] about that
with this other [ __ ] or i do care but i
i can't it doesn't matter because i have
to give
x amount of money to x person people
also forget
what like you did a [ __ ] movie and then
no one cares yeah
they don't they forget that you did the
[ __ ] movie yeah
well speak for yourself must be easy
must sounds nice
goodbye um
anyhow yeah you've got mail
hey neil and bianca i have a
relationship
question for you here so what do you do
when someone just kind of refuses to
accept an apology
and it seems like there's nothing you
can do
to get them to accept it it's like they
don't even believe
you're sincere or earnest even though
you are
um and for the sake of argument let's
just say
you know you [ __ ] up and you owe them
an apology
what what can you do just grand gesture
wait it out
any advice would be greatly appreciated
what did he do for argument's sake
for arguments he [ __ ] up him no you
know i think there's nothing
you can it sounds like a girl he [ __ ]
up
and he's apologized and she's not ex i
mean there's a difference between
this is when you get into like i accept
your apology
what does that mean right you can still
be
[ __ ] mad you can still
hold it against them in some
facet of your body or mind you still
are like that's this [ __ ] you
did that thing to me
yeah and i forgive i
but and and vice versa i've apologized
to people
for [ __ ] and they've never forgiven me
and they're
they're somebody who still shits
on me [ __ ] talks me and i like very
clearly
like i made a mistake but
in this case that person likes the
agreement better than they like
whatever the the piece would be or
i've had a situation i rarely don't
accept an apology but
when someone's just so blatantly
rude or [ __ ] up or whatever it is
and then their apology makes it worse
like it's like
i i did that consciously it's like
you did that con you're i don't want
anything
meaning their admission their admission
is just like yeah
i was knowingly doing that oh yeah
that's
sometimes an apology makes it you're
mad again yeah i'm with you but my
question is
should they have not admitted to that
level no it's
like we're cool but yeah it's
you know not everything can be
resurrected not everything can be
yeah sometimes it's scorched earth
sometimes your behavior just scorched
earth where
thanks for the apology i don't take like
the apology helps
me not think terrible of you but the
relationship is
like it's just there's no bringing it
back yeah um
yeah it's you can apologize you can be
scorched and you're like
yeah i i
i i get that you you know it's like i've
had situations where
people did [ __ ] where i was like that's
so foundational
that there's no point in
continuing right it's so foundational
that there's no point it's
it it's the thing i was saying about a
thing where it's like i felt like i was
paying for insurance
and then it turns out i wasn't covered
for that you're like right why would i
ever get insurance from you again
like for what it's not worth the paper
it's printed on it i may use an old
phrase did you send me the old man
phrase tweet
[Music]
maybe somebody sent me a tweet where
it's like
you're dating when you're dating an
older dude and it's great and then he'll
say
some like you know he says like like six
and one half a dozen the other and you
remember how old he is
which i can't remember i read that i
don't know if i said it to you um but i
thought of you
thank you thank you for almost doing
what you almost did
um what else we got lst
ner i love it that's nice listening to
the podcast right now and you yes you're
talking about
masturbation neil says it's gross
if your partner is there bianca says
is a [ __ ] you however what are your
thoughts on
mutual masturbation whether it's
you touching yourself your partner
touching them
they he herself
what are your thoughts on that love the
bond let me know
thanks i'm fine with that that's like a
form of sex to me
yeah it just it feels like
the only reason why you do that there's
some sort of constraint though
that's like in a jam there's i mean it's
also like an
interval yeah or it could be yeah yeah
okay right okay you get me on that well
okay
a little interval oh yeah it's like an
interval
and um i have absolutely no problem with
it as a like uh
okay now at ten o'clock in bed
when you the you like toss the computer
and then you just like
stare at each other like it's a contest
not with it but
don't like i'm good done um
get my you get the things out you get my
blanket shot
baseball jerk off my bait my
my base my base pots my ba my blaze pods
my blaze pods um yeah that i'm not with
but you know i don't you know
i don't like it okay i like
us both
each other exacting i don't like
me uh me and mine no you do
you and i do me yeah that's when
you know he has his life i have my life
and then we meet up and you're like
yeah the better they don't live together
the closer
you get the i don't know whatever none
of them work so
so what am i even talking about but i
know masturbation works
and uh i'm
it's fine i think it's fine it's
admissible but as
a practice if it's if there's no
like sex exacted on the other person
then it's then what are you doing yeah
then you're doing then you're doing
blaze pods
ultimately thank you goodbye
you've got mayonnaise hi neil and banks
swing in a minute you guys just read a
study that 78
of all drug charges are for less than a
gram
and i just want you to know that is
complete [ __ ]
uh it's not that uh people are getting
charged for low amounts
of drugs it's just that there's no way
anyone knows that number i'm a criminal
justice data analyst
i've worked a number of states kind of
looking at the data regarding drugs
that's reliable and no one tracks that
information
no one knows the actual weight of any of
the drugs in order to get that
information to look at
uh trafficking levels in one state we
had to do a file review
of each individual police report and
people are just guessing there's no way
a study can say
78 of all drug charges or anything
that's insane that you would think
people could track data like that
police departments uh not that organized
look at charles
i'm uh yeah i don't trust him no no i
i like it i don't trust his voice a
little
i think i believe him i believe that
he's but you get
charged foreign right you get and you
all yeah you get charged and convicted
based on the amount they say the amount
in the charge
so i don't get why it's or they if they
don't say the amount
it's somewhere less or more than
something
right based on yeah there's mandatory
minimums right so i don't get
how that's not trackable uh
well you have to file a report or
whatever the [ __ ] he said
so that he had me on the thing and then
he's like in order to do that you'd have
to ask
well then i'm betting they asked i think
a study
asked or or i mean you're putting us in
a top position because
maybe you're absolutely right but ah
you didn't it wasn't argue great but
then again i cut you off
but also so it does make sense that
most people aren't walking around with
kilos
so i don't i like it does it it makes
sense i
i feel like it's trackable i know people
have been arrested for drug charges
with a small amount and they still got
busted
and that amount like correlates to like
charge like yeah as someone like in
because now they're not
prosecuting under a certain amount of or
yeah like i don't i think he needs to
go back to work and ask some questions
right
but maybe he's right send us another
audio don't open wacky the problem is he
opened wacky
he's morning zoo
and and that and and you lose
credibility you do
other than uh the bubble of the love
sponge
hulk hogan court trial where i mean
you want to talk about zooker
[Music]
they they said it was uh that
there was some meme or joke where they
know it was hulk hogan
in the video because he kept calling the
woman brother goodbye you've got mail
here's my question if netflix came to
each of you and said
we'll hire the director you want to make
a documentary film about a topic you're
interested in
who are you choosing and what topic uh
that's a good question good question and
it's also
a toughie yeah we needed this who do you
i had it well i think i pitched it on
here about just a documentary about cops
but cops just law enforcement in america
and what angle all the history
and how it came to be like slave
catchers all that [ __ ]
and i would nominate ezra
that would be mine too um
yeah ezra because it would be exhaustive
and he can
he's like a the thing he did in in the
in the um oj1 it's like synthesize it's
like orc
he's orchestrated [ __ ] five different
massive stories it's like five different
documentaries intercut
well i'm going with all ezra because
why not um probably
i would really love a deep
dive into wealth in this country
and all forms um i found myself doing
deeper
and deeper dives uh just
the like from like the history of it
the history of formation of this country
who how people got wealth obviously that
comes with land and that's been touched
on a lot of things but really who didn't
get it who was prevented from getting
wealth
who were the people that shot to the top
like unions everything just
wealth how like what was the most
important uh
just significant
points in history that propelled certain
people to wealth
their downfall and then like now just
y2k 2000's certain well certain things
fall like i just
wealth in this country is just so um
foundational
there is a really interesting movie it's
not
good per se but it's [ __ ] interesting
called the american ruling class
okay and it's genre-wise
bananas interesting but you should i
don't even know where to find it it was
like one of these things that you
stumbled on
but it's not about it's about it's just
kind of about rich people
i can't it's like a lie though like i
remember
i was going to the huntington library or
the
botanical gardens in pasadena and the
house is so pretty
yeah and there was one with like eagles
and american flags everywhere
so of course i hopped on zillow i was
like i want to see what this looks like
inside
and then i went into a wormhole on this
property
it's owned by these chinese billionaires
first of all you'd never know there was
nobody there
it was full of american flags it was
owned by these
this chinese family they own like a
bunch of things on the block
blog is hot and i want i'm like i want
to know about these people so [ __ ]
bad
why do they have this property yeah why
aren't they here why is nobody
there what do they do yeah how is it
intertwined and the deeper you go it's
just the more complicated it gets or
even the
koch brothers like when you start go i'm
like i didn't they
they're like because the the thing that
ko brothers do the way they make money
is [ __ ] boring
what like they manage oil fields or some
like
not even the oil it's not even we get
oil
it's like we man it's just it's like uh
they make like they build political and
yeah like
or or warren buffett it's not like sexy
no no no they're not i don't want to
deep dive into one person but i do
want to understand how wealth interacts
in this country
because i think there is something that
we don't it's just on such a grand scale
that we can't
i'll call us goodbye ezra you've got
mail
hello neil and bianca i am a single
white male living in st
louis missouri i'm 33 and i feel like i
am missing all those big benchmarks that
everyone seems to be hitting around me
i.e getting married having children
holding down an impressive sounding job
i actually was a financial advisor but i
quit
because i felt like i wasn't meant for
for that necessarily
um i actually tried to stand up a couple
times
horribly but anyway i'm considering
taking a trip down to south america to
maybe experience something akin to what
you've described regarding a shaman led
ayahuasca trip
i would love any tips for what city or
cities to check out in south america how
to find a good shaman
and how to prepare for the ayahuasca
trip much appreciated
uh i'm with this guy i think there are a
lot of people that
are don't they are misfits right
my i may be doing a show about it a
new three mikes type show starting in
august in new york about this sort of
area
so i'm with him in that regard um you
mean not
fitting not just knowing [ __ ] all the
[ __ ]
like you don't do the i everything i am
is like
the the least
popular single old
uh no kids don't eat meat don't drink
don't smoke weed
um solitary job work at night
i have a podcast that's you know okay
that's the one thing i do do this
pretty pretty pretty common uh so
whatever it's just
it's not even like i'm prosecuted it's
just more isolation
um the i mean
i don't it's so you know i wish you luck
i
i don't know i i've never been to south
america and in terms of
uh doing it they say intention's
important and i think it is but
it i think the other part of it is
you got to be open to whatever happens
when you're doing it you can't be like
no
we just this wasn't what i wanted wait a
minute
yeah like we said i said we're gonna
talk about my brother
robbie i don't have one um so surprise
have an intention and um
and then see what happens yeah
so good good i like the speed of his
questions
horrible song it doesn't work keep
playing it worst song
since smallpox blanket statement goodbye
you've got me hey neil maggie first i
wanted to thank you both that was
absolutely the worst year of my life but
this podcast truly got me through some
dark times
here's my issue i have incredibly strong
feelings from my best friend and i'm
debating whether to tell her or not
the problem is that we live together i'm
not sure she feels the same way
also i got out of a long relationship
eight months ago so i'm still not really
looking for
a relationship just yet uh better to
keep things the way they are
or be honest with her about how i feel
for context i'm a bi
23 year old man and she's a straight 24
year old woman
that sounds like a oh my long shot
on paper that sounds like a terrible
because i women don't like younger guys
very at that age
she's not that young right but i'm
saying not young but just
there's something about at that age
where you're like i don't know
oh well if you're if you live with her
as a roommate and you're her best friend
probably not probably probably already
not even in there yeah yeah yeah
and then this this is what i don't like
i'm not really looking for a
relationship just yet
you want to [ __ ] around with your
basically i'm like hey i want to [ __ ] my
roommate
yeah any guy that has a roommate and
it's a woman
above yeah a certain
level and by the way not really that
high because
it's a local it's a local gig um
it's uh yeah you want to [ __ ] your
roommate but
but i love when guys go i just got out
of something when it was seven years ago
okay it's a little eight months isn't
that long
isn't it like is it is long enough to
get over somebody right
um so this guy's saying i want to [ __ ]
my roommate but
not get serious with my best friend
roommate who is donating a kidney
you're about to have a another bad year
if you do this
it's not it's not and you know what
friend we can't help you
um we're not going to be there for you
this time goodbye you've got
mail the pew research sent some trend
someone sent
some interracial marriage oh they want
us to do it
um steady rise in intermarriage in the
u.s
uh 17 of newlyweds
are inter interracial
and ten percent
are that's over this is one of these
things where stats don't know how to
sell themselves
yeah look at these things overall you're
so bad
amount of married overall the pool of
married people is 10
is interracial but new marriages are 17
so um so cool
age the amount of intermarrying asians
is going down
bad news for the yellow fevered white
sorry gents from 33 i don't know what
else to say
yellow it's their term i didn't think of
it um and by them i mean
the asians um that's it from 33
of asians marrying outside of blacks are
up blacks are up with a bullet five
percent in 1980 18
in 2015 or in the black guys it's either
that's either good or some would say
bad who would say uh like who's that guy
that's on the breakfast club that
roy and trayvon send me the videos all
the time doctor something
he's just like oh he's like oh yeah
he's like no no no no yeah do not but
then it's funny because everyone always
counters that guy i don't know my just
really comments that
saying like don't do interracial
marriage and then
a lot of people counter him with the
fact that he you know i don't know
enough to quote well by
saying you don't do it it almost
guarantees that you did it at some point
i mean you know what i mean just the the
rules the law of
of uh of contradiction and and
right uh i did it guys don't always
trust me yeah
and and also you wouldn't espouse
something unless you were doing it
interesting there's as i've said a
million times on here
human beings are running such a small
profit margin on morality
that in order for you to go out
proselytizing
something's wrong unless like i was
saying before unless you're [ __ ]
weird unless you're a weird gandhi
ml like if you're those people are weird
and i don't mean bad i just mean they're
they are abnormal they're
they're they're rare so if you're the
rare person who's proselytizing who's
not doing
something horrible god bless you
martin luther king goodbye you've got me
been listening from the start and wanted
to say that i saw binky before i heard a
lot of her
i thought she was a she was beautiful
from the start but appreciated her
intelligence more as i heard each
episode
i now believe she is as beautiful as she
is intelligent i love that she speaks
multiple language
is is well versed in a multitude of
topics
provides balanced perspectives and is
super chill
i'm a i'm much older than her but i
like to be her when i when i grow up
pretty creepy
neil thanks for chappelle show that's it
um that's the end of it thanks for
that's for an unflattering comment oh
this she's a revenge
that's for an unflattering comment you
made in passing about filipinos in
in a past episode i don't remember the
exact comment
but i remember that it made me narrow my
eyes
despite that i continue to be a tuesday
listener as you're clearly intelligent
enough to have befriended bianca
thanks for the entertainment i mean i i
won't even make it
a joke about narrowing the eyes that
kneel that
look that joke makes itself right that's
rstnle that's off the top
that's a given i don't even see that
don't suck
and the unflattering comment i believe
was you said something about curvy
asians and i said
of course you're speaking of filipinos
well that's not unflattering at all
that's exactly right she saw it as
unflattering we're from a different
culture we like curve
or do you uh well
never mind controversial real
controversial you sometimes
i don't know depends it's just not too
curved
uh or more curved it's a it depends how
you define cards just as long as they
don't have mental health issues
uh good skin don't look like a dude
goodbye
you've got mail hey a few episodes there
was a brief discussion on how you can't
support both cancer culture and criminal
justice reform
super interesting stuff was just
wondering if the source material was an
article book or interview that you could
direct
me to for further reading it was called
the
little book of restorative justice
yeah the the the comparisons
i don't know if that's what they were
talking about yeah i think you're right
the little book of your story
yeah yes so my friend is writing a um
el pequeno libro de justica restora tiva
um why is this in espanol don't worry
about it um
so yeah howard zaire i believe
yep howard's here yeah so so that's the
book
that's the book and yeah it makes sense
if you think about it
yep it's a pretty bad way to end the
podcast
thanks for listening but that's
all the letters we have that was it yeah
but i got stuff i can do so
wait like with your blaze paws yeah i've
i have to beat my personal best oh this
is interesting come on
so i you know i do my one-legged squat
lunges
well no we didn't know that two uh
you know squat lunge just one leg at a
time you you
lunge basically you just like i just
isn't that called like a
genuflect a tarzarian squad or something
a russian squad
it's you just and it's [ __ ] romanian
romanian i'm not sure
it may be uh one-legged squat and um
i would you like to guess what weights
i use for each
hand 30 30. 50 50.
50 50. pretty nice pretty nice
i do a pretty nice job do you do one no
i did the other day i did i started with
13
13 12 11 10.
what's your goal because if it's to have
a bigger ball
you're doing it then you're doing wrong
you got to do like heavy low reps i
do high reps is tone i want both
i want the best of both worlds i also do
the ones
that anyway the question is
i texted blake okay and said what do you
do
okay um do you want to guess what he
does
seven five 75 each 75 each
he does 65 each but said it's light work
oh that's it it's like he could probably
that's him in that pool that
yeah i mean he does 65
so so as not to wear himself
yeah because he's bad knees um but it
was interesting to know but he said it's
light work and then he hit me with like
50 is good though he modified okay i
have a question for you yeah go ahead
do yeah do you find all of your close
friends interesting
yeah they all are like or is there some
that are just like
hang arounds where it's like i love like
dead weight
i love them but yeah i might most of my
good friends i met through work
so there's something already interesting
about them
yeah or we like each other or like we
[ __ ] around with each other or there's a
long history
or but in terms of people i haven't met
through work
it's a little hard because i've been
i've been in school since i was 19.
yeah so and everyone no one moved from
philly to new york have you met all your
good friends family
no bichon i've known
bijan bijan whatever you want to call
him i've known him for
17 years sick never came over for
persian dinner
no they're in baltimore i met a sister
so okay yeah that's pretty good
i feel like when you meet a family
member it feels like a
solid yeah like a real thing yeah if you
me if they meet your family member
it's a little less of like you're
probably not a psycho
if they're going to introduce you to
their family but if you never get that
invite it's like no
there's just yeah yeah no they
miss their their their mother they don't
like meeting people um are you ever
gonna throw one of your
so you may not go to a party but i heard
that you used to throw a party every
year yeah i used to have an ice cream a
cake party and will is that a pie party
sorry is that ever going to come back
it i don't think it's going to come back
neal i
didn't know the but it was just
stressful oh it was yeah it's just
stressful
plus i got binocular vision so i gotta
it make i have anxiety see-through
binocular dysfunction i have to i
literally have to get to the eye doctor
before they close okay
well so so in short what we're trying to
say is that we don't take this [ __ ] so
[Music]
[Music]
huh